[Musique]
grégoire thonnat bonjour bonjour merci
et au creux sur le plateau de ce vip sur
tv5 118
vous êtes ici car vous avez écrit pas
mal de petits livres dont deux qui nous
intéresse plus particulièrement à savoir
le petit quizz versailles et le tout
frais tout beau tout neuf tout rose to
he has il vient de naître et celle marie
antoinette
voilà ça c'est là que tu alors à côté
moi un petit peu votre vie monsieur
alors vous avez baptiste orient dont je
ne suis pas historien
en revanche je suis passionné d'histoire
depuis que je suis un petit garçon
je travaille avec les historiens
évidemment des livres d'histoire dont
j'ai toujours un comité de relecture
non je suis pas historien j'ai la
passion de l'histoire et j'ai ma passion
de partager l'histoire parce que ben
voilà j'aime bien partager ce que je
connais et puis l'idée on peut peut-être
parler de l'idée de la jeunesse du petit
quizz qui est sorti il ya un peu plus de
quatre ans maintenant qui est toujours
une rencontre
cette collection d'être co éditeur avec
pierre de taille à cardy sion pierre de
taulhac voilà c'est vous qui avez eu
l'idée a le format il ya quatre hommes
de questions et c'était là quatre ans il
ya quatre ans je suis allé le voir en me
disant on va fêter le centenaire de la
grande guerre
je me suis aperçu qu'autour de moi mon
entourage mes amis il avait perdu les
repères essentiels sur ce sujet là qui
pourtant est un sujet majeur de notre
histoire qu'est la bascule en fait du la
matrice du 20e siècle et l'idée c'était
de bien mais redonner les éléments clés
pour comprendre quelque chose dont on va
parler pendant quatre ans et on parle
encore puisque c'est la dernière année
du centenaire et donc j'ai dit à pierre
on va pas faire un livre savant ce que
je ne saurais pas faire
enfin on va faire un livre le plus
simple le plus facile le plus abordable
possible sur le fond sur la forme et sur
le prix donc rendre ce sujet là si
possible et c'est l'ambition pour un
public de reprendre l'idée de tintin de
7 à 77 ans voilà donc sous forme de
questions réponses
voilà donc c'est vous qui cherchez les
questions c'est vous qui cherchez les
réponses et donc le but c'est de donner
quoi l'essentiel
l'idée c'est d'offrir un petit tableau
très facile à digérer qui donne envie si
possible d'aller plus loin sur le sujet
mais dire voilà alors sur le premier sur
le petit cousin grande guerre c'est 100
questions parce que cette centenaire en
100 questions on va vous donner les
éléments clés que vous devez savoir sur
le sujet de la grande guerre et puis
après il ya toujours une chronologie
dans les livres ce qu'on en parle
d'histoire il ya une sélection
d'ouvragés de ressources document
d'ouvragés de films de docu qui sont des
ressources documentaires sur le sujet
l'idée c'est de dire si vous voulez
aller plus loin voilà une sélection un
éventail de sélection et puis sur
certains sel car la grande guerre c'est
ça une sélection de sites à aller voir
aller visiter le site de la bataille de
verdun aller dans la somme
allez sur le champ de bataille du
mémorial du linge dans les vosges
allez voir aussi sur place parce que
l'histoire aussi elle se vit sur place
ouais ben oui donc en fait il ya
l'essentiel et plus si affinités voilà
c'est jamais que d ouvrir des portes
pour les gens et donc ces jeunes des
petits livres d'ouverture sur un sujet
très bien donc la grande guerre c'était
le premier après vous avez enchaîné avec
quoi la marine j'ai travaillé pour le
musée national de la marine
il me fait un petit quizz sur l'histoire
de la marine d'accord 80 questions
réponses une galerie de portraits de dix
marins essentiel donc de lapérouse à
tabarly et puis une sélection de deux
bâtiments emblématiques de l'histoire de
la marine donc du premier sous-marin du
premier bateau à vapeur
voilà qu'après vous avez continué cette
collection qui marche très bien j'ai
l'impression qu'ils qui va me plaît
c'est un bonheur en fait ce qu'on se dit
tous les jours et pierre de taille axés
que ça fonctionne bien d'un accueil des
médias qui est formidable
il adore ça parce qu'en fait vous savez
vous le savez vous avez les médias ont
peu de temps on est dans l'immédiateté
donc en fait on leur offre de la matière
prémâché donc ils adorent ça
vous prenez quatre sujets qu à quatre
questions ça fait un sujet avec un angle
et voilà donc on a eu une vraie un très
bon accueil et une bonne couverture
médiatique à chaque fois et puis on a en
a des ventes qui nous permettent de
continuer à en sortir d'autres et ça
c'est pas donné à tout le monde
voilà ce qu'on fait on aime ce qu'on
fait moi je suis passionné vraiment
d'histoire et voilà d'accord donc pour
celui ci donc versailles qui est sorti
en 2015
absolument la première édition a été
réédité c'est la deuxième édition la
main tout récemment qui seront jointes
mans qui ressort avec avec manon parata
là donc ça bah c'est la preuve du succès
comment comment se mettront dans la peau
du lecteur pour se dire enfin comment
trouve-t-on les questions qu réellement
alors il ya un principe puisque on est
sur des sujets historiques les questions
ils sont toujours chronologique on
commence par le début on finit par la
fin
voilà rien d'original mais on peut aussi
aller picorer et prendre une page sur
versailles et
mais vous pardon comment vous avez
comment vous ai dit je vais prendre ces
questions là ah ça c'est un vrai nom
c'est pas un secret du tout c'est que je
lis énormément
oui sur le sujet ce qu'il faut savoir ce
qui va intéresser des gens ben en fait
de poser une question s'il se fout si on
se moque de la réponse est non non non
non en fait moi je me laisse assez
regrette c'est un vrai boulot ccc la
ligne éditoriale de cette collection je
me mets à la place du béotien je me dis
quand je viens à versailles qu'est-ce
qu'il faut que je sache il ya des
évidences qui n'en sont pas genre bah
pourquoi versailles est à versailles
pour le château de versailles était
construit personnes ça c'est une
question bas c'est une question dont on
parlera en fait bon c'est lié à
l'histoire de louis xiv dû perdre 13
donc voilà j'ai travaillé j'ai travaillé
sur un autre livre l'année dernière sur
l'histoire de la police
l'histoire de la police ces trois cents
ans d'histoire
d'où vient le mot police sépare est une
évidence mais non c'est nécessaire le
parent d'ailleurs je vous pose la
question d'où vient le mot police je
réfléchirai
voilà ça vient du latin polita est en
fait qui est l'art de gouverner la ville
voilà je le prononce mac je mon latin
mouillac sans atteindre la voilà mais
donc commencer par sa une des premières
questions seydoux vient quelle est
l'origine de ce mot et quand on explique
l'origine du mot déjà on commence à dire
beaucoup sur le sujet hockey et est ce
que le fait d'aller sur place vous
provoque des questions auxquelles vous
n'auriez pas pensé je ne peux pas
travailler que dans des livres c'est bon
c'est en chambre alors c'est
indispensable
et je vais vous faire un aveu quand j'ai
commencé à travailler il ya un an sur
quand le château nous a dit voilà on
voudrait faire un autre livre c'est
super le premier on va on voudrait faire
un sujet sur marie antoinette
en fait je n'avais jamais été au petit
trianon
t'es pas vrai alors je connais le
château rouge venait des jardins mais
j'avais une île petit mil grand trianon
donc j'ai dit la première des choses
c'est que fait moins une visite je pars
je passe une journée et je visite de
fond en comble le petit trianon
il est vrai et ça c'est très personnel
quand j'ai visité ce cet endroit et
notamment un certain moment je pense au
petit théâtre de la reine qui se visite
mais sur réservation et d'un guide
j'ai eu du vrai moment d'émotion voilà
qui vous ont provoqué les questions bien
des questions ben oui en fait parce que
le petit théâtre quand vous prenez de
l'histoire du petit théâtre de la reine
ça c'est lié à la évidemment à
l'histoire de marie antoinette qui
conquit qui s'installe au trianon pour
échapper à la pesanteur de l'éthique n
est pour échapper à sa condition de
rennes
elle aime jouer la comédie hier pour
cela elle fait construire sur le domaine
de trion un petit théâtre est un théâtre
de poche et qui lui permet d'échapper
voilà deux de se transposer un petit peu
sur un autre personnage là de poche qui
faisait poche
c'est vraiment très pratique on peut se
promener avec avant la visite pendant la
visite au retour continuer la visite à
la voiture en fait visiter les enfants
se poser des questions lorsque j'ai
remarqué c'est que les questions sont
soit sur des faits politiques sociaux
des faits complètement architecturaux
tous les on a besoin de tous les
domaines on était pas survolé mais comme
on dit on essaye autant que faire ce peu
d'avoir quelque chose de complet donc
oui à y avoir des données chiffrées il
va y avoir il faut 10 et 5 e mais pas
que et puis ce qui m'intéresse aussi
c'est que souvent des anecdotes des
petites anecdotes vont éclairer la
grande histoire voilà et puis par
exemple quand vous donnez les surnoms
chou d'amour et mousseline a
sérieusement fait on est dans l'affectif
donne de la proximité personnages bien
sûr parce que c'était une mère je suis
une mère aussi des tumeurs non je
reprends une situation que n'a pas non
pardon ne peux pas je suis un peu mais
c'est plus la mer voilà je suis un père
non dans une phrase de céline dur je
suis une mère aussi
ah pardon c'est ainsi que c'est un
sketch posez moi
on sort de sujets enfin l'avenir donc
oui donc des questions à la fois
sérieuse historique des données et puis
les petites anecdotes qui vont éclairer
et puis qui rythment le récit entre
guillemets voilà hockey et vous avez des
projets de oui oui pratiquement en fait
on a cette chance c'est que les projets
en appelle d'autres et donc pour la
rentrée donc en septembre octobre j'ai
pas encore la date
je travaille pour la réalisation d'un
livre sur clemenceau georges clemenceau
puisque c'est la dernière année du
centenaire et selanne et clemenceau
aussi puisque comme vous savez
clemenceau était président du conseil
la dernière née de la guerre d'où ce
surnom de père la victoire voilà encore
un père voilà au miel génial mais
écoutez à gros merci quand exactement là
donc ça s'est vendu dans les librairies
du château alors tous évidemment dans
tout type là château et toutes les
bonnes librairies de france et de
navarre très bien les sites en ligne et
ça existe en anglais et ça existe en
anglais faire cadeau à offrir à des
anglais des anglophones ou allophones
les touristes et sap est un jeu très
sympa dans la voiture pendant un long
voyage bonne idée pour offrir pour un
voilà on est un dîner chez des amis
plutôt qu'un bouquet de fleurs ça change
un peu et puis apprendre en s'amusant
merci beaucoup merci et à très vite pour
d'autres livres
[Musique]